there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people in time you
will know what it's like to lose feel so
desperately that you're right we just
gotta love Tony don't hold our
armor prototype for tops new shield yet
to fail all the stack
[Applause]
read it
run Dustin's suddenly those offhanded
remarks during spider-man homecoming
make a lot more sense now now we know
where that Hulkbuster came from so this
is gonna be video all about Hulk and the
Hulkbuster during the infinity war
trailer and during the movie because
they're using him for some silver surfer
stuff from the Thanos Infinity Gauntlet
storyline and they're having some fun
with the character at the expense of
Avengers age of Ultron just a funny idea
on the twist of what the Hulk buster
represents in the fight that they had
during age of Ultron so if you are
finding me for the first time we're
doing Marvel every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's even
giveaway stuff happening at the end of
the video too but starting with the
funny stuff first so a lot of people saw
this trailer in the way that the Hulk
buster lands it lands the way that the
Hulk lands when he jumps really far it
doesn't land the way that Tony Stark
lands when he's wearing the Hulk buster
so people are like oh there's got to be
somebody else inside there
maybe it's the Hulk himself because
there's a corresponding shot of a piece
of the Hulkbuster armor standing next to
banner while Black Widow is just
watching him like oh my god I haven't
seen this guy since Avengers age of
Ultron where the hell did you go big guy
and she has that smile on her face just
like wow this is an awkward moment so
the idea is that she's standing out in
this field in Wakanda here and it's like
oh here comes stark in the Hulkbuster or
whatever in out climbs banner and it's a
funny ha ha moment but rewind to the
beginning of the movie why would the
Hulk be inside the Hulk buster other
than for it to be a very funny moment
there's got to be an actual reason for
it the reason why is probably just for
pure transportation reasons like they
probably want to get the Hulk Buster
down there because they want to have the
Hulk Buster fight black dwarf when he
lands with the other outriders now this
big invasion here the armor itself we
know is in upstate New York at the
Avengers facility per Spider Man
homecoming when happy was loading all
the gear off the Avengers Tower this is
all happening after the events of the
spider-man homecoming so whoever they've
sold the tower to they finished that up
and there's no more Avenger stuff inside
there so there's the scene of Hulk
crashing through the sanctum dr. strange
and Wong looking down like what the hell
is Bruce Banner doing here they always
seem to know who weird people
or when they show up like your brother
Loki is here what is he doing here he
caused a lot of problems the last time
he was around so he shows up in Hulk is
probably serving the role of the Silver
Surfer during Thanos quest a lot of you
guessed that during the trailer like are
they gonna give him the Silver Surfer
storyline where he warns dr. strange
about fan OHS so in that storyline what
happens is his Silver Surfer is just
going across the universe he's The
Herald of Galactus so he's out on his
normal business he comes across Thanos
who's in the process of battling other
powerful cosmic beings to get the
infinity gems Thanos punts him across
the universe and he crash-lands in dr.
Strange's sanctum and gives him this
great warning that death is coming for
everyone so he becomes the first member
of the Avengers to find out what's going
on and he warns everyone else so careful
for spoilers for the end of thor
ragnarok if you haven't seen that movie
yet at the end of that movie it looks
like they noses ship shows up so it
sounds like when goes down on the
ship here Loki sends everyone in
opposite directions using the tesseract
so that's how Hulk gets back into
Earth's atmosphere but because this is
like a two-and-a-half-hour movie Iron
Man probably instantly detects Hulk in
Earth's atmosphere comes to find him and
then meets Doctor Strange they have sort
of that funny moment the comedy of just
seeing the Hulk lying there and all that
debris in wondering how he got there
wondering how he was able to break
through all the enchantments protecting
the sanctum sanctorum because as cool as
it is seeing all these characters on
screen for the first time you have to
remember that the sanctum is one of the
most protected places on the earth and
Hulk literally just crashes right
through the barrier it'd be like him
tearing through enchantments like tissue
paper and then a lot of you also
detected that Tony whips out the cell
phone the Captain America gave him at
the end of Civil War like he's instantly
calling cap holy get the band back
together are you Tony
stank
Tony I wish we agreed on the Accords I
really do
I know you're doing what you believe in
and that's all any of us can do that's
all any of us should if you need us if
you need me
[Music]
I'll be there so you see them all
standing here he's still banner in the
street while they're looking up at the
sky this is probably when Thanos ship
first comes down and then they need to
get to Wakanda for some reason so at
some point later in the film they needed
to take all their resources down there
for whatever this big final battle is
but what might end up happening is is
like you see banner standing here he
hasn't turned into the Hulk again he
might be afraid to turn back into the
Hulk but they still need to get him down
to Wakanda so Tony is probably like I
have an idea and then you just cut to a
scene of him inside the Hulk Buster
flying to Wakanda so when it lands here
for the first time he still climbs out
in his banner but obviously we've seen
the trailer scene of them all running
into battle behind Captain America and
Black Panther here he's gone fully Hulk
we see the Hulk Buster way down here in
the field but black widows running
behind them here so either Friday is
Auto piloting the Hulkbuster during this
big fight for Black Widow climbs into it
but you can kind of see how they're
doing a lot of comic book fan OHS quest
stuff with the characters that they have
on screen like they don't have a Silver
Surfer even if the Fox deal goes through
they've already shot the movie they're
not gonna add Silver Surfer in the next
couple of weeks but I know a lot of you
have been asking about that renewed box
Disney talks like they say that they're
back in the meeting room now trying to
hash out a deal for them to either buy
most of Fox's assets or find a sharing
arrangement so if that were to happen
right away I think the first thing that
Marvel would go for would be the
Fantastic Four characters because Reed
Richards would work really well with the
characters they already have on screen
he's one of the Illuminati and they
could use him in a limited way the way
that they used dr. strange so like
Doctor Strange had a solo movie but for
the most part he just popped up in other
people's films just because the
character himself isn't quite as popular
as some of the other a-list Avengers but
after that if they have the Marvel
cosmic universe the James Gunn's been
hyping up I did a video about that a
little while ago they could use Galactus
as the big bad of the next phase of
Marvel cosmic films they could do
Ultimates like you can't really do
Altima Talca lactis it would just be
really awesome to see comic-book
versions of a lot of those Fox
characters now x-men is kind of a sipper
thing we could talk about x-men vs.
Avengers but the x-men timeline is so
messy
that if they do wind up making the deal
sharing characters and using x-men
characters I think it'll be on a limited
basis like they would go for Wolverine
and they would try to do a more comic
book II version of that character
eventually but let me know in the
comments they get access to the Fox
characters which ones do you want them
to grab first for the initial phase for
films I think a lot of people are just
waiting for Fantastic Four like they've
been drug through the mud so much people
just want to see a good version of some
of those characters or at least one of
them being Reed Richards but there's
plenty more Avengers on the way there
obviously be more black panther dropping
really soon so just leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments there is
a new round of that imax ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave an Avengers related
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last video
Brandon Navarro please private message
me so I can get your contact details to
answer your question Clark Gregg in real
life actually said that Coulson would
not be going back into the movies in
that way if he does we might get a cameo
during Captain Marvel set in the past
but we can talk about that if we learn
more about Captain Marvel so click here
to learn all about the infinity gems and
click here to learn all about Stokes
backstory and his powers in the last
Jedi thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight